welcome to another episode of matrix
math we're going to talk about upper and
lower triangular matrices and some other
properties so first what is an upper or
lower triangular matrix let's just go
ahead and reveal that real quick here
say we have a matrix called a and if it
is lower triangular say lower I'll just
say try AG save some space here then
that means okay well we look at this
this center point here and if this and
everything below it is a number and
everything above it is a zero and it's
lower triangular
well that might make not make a lot of
sense let's say this is we'll just keep
it simple and make it a 3x3 so if we got
a 1 4 6 9 2 over here and maybe an 8
over here and then we have zeros up here
this is lower triangular because well I
guess it gets its name from this
triangle at the lower portion so there's
a lower triangular matrix and if we want
to do an upper one well you can guess
then it's going to be the upper portion
we have matrix B I'm gone black and it
equals
and let's make an upper upper triangular
triangular 1010 that looks better
all right then it's will go off the
center and if the upper portion it's
filled with numbers and the rest is 0 or
it doesn't necessarily have to be
numbers it just has to be nonzero
elements so 1 4 6 negative 7 to 9 and
then 0 0 0 this would be upper
triangular
now one of the interesting properties of
these there's a couple I'm going to talk
about here really just just two
different properties is if you multiply
two lower triangular matrices together
you end up with the result of another
lower triangular matrix and you can test
that out if you want so this a here if
we were doing a times a we'd end up with
another lower triangular matrix lower
triangular matrix I'll call it LTM and
that goes the same for it a to any power
so a to the fourth power so a times a
times a times a is still going to be a
lower triangular matrix now another
interesting thing about it is if you
transpose one of the one of these it
turns into an upper so if we do a
transposed it's now going to be a upper
I'm going to spell it all out upper
triangular matrix so it would look more
I would go to that form with the
transpose and if you transpose it again
it goes back to 2a
so those are some of the properties and
you can kind of scale those all over the
place like you can do well I don't know
how much I really want to get into it
that's that's the basics of it really is
you multiply them together you stick
with the same triangular pre transpose
them it turns into the other type and
that's really all there is to them and
by book definition you see stuff like oh
okay by book how many people is that
going to troll by book definition you
see things like we'll say a I J where I
is the row J is the column you see
things
like when I is less than J I might as
well just type this out like when I is
less than J
or okay sorry you'll say okay a to the
IJ pretend those are subsets equals zero
when I is less than J which basically
means the field is zero when I is less
than J and that would be a lower
triangular so I be in the row
JB in the column so if we're in column
two Row one then I is less than J it's
going to equal zero so that's typically
how its defined in a book I prefer to
just look at it in a more realistic way
of well this way but whatever works for
you academically you'll see this type of
stuff and of course there's all sorts of
other mathematical ways of representing
it okay I think that's gonna do it for
this upper and lower triangular I think
I've beat it into the ground at this
point
hope you enjoyed thanks for watching my
video on matrix math and look forward to
the next one you can show some sport by
leaving a like and watch the rest of the
series if you would like to learn more
about matrices and further your
development with understanding this type
of stuff alright peace out guys